hey youtubers is Charlie happy wholock
week the game is on so this week I'll be
alternating Doctor Who and Sherlock
videos every day just in honor of the
Christmas special and Sherlock series 3
everything's gonna be a mixture of like
fun list videos as well as Q day's
breakdown videos and reviews of the
actual content so like a review of the
Christmas special and a review that
Sherlock mini-episode if there's any
special kind of content that you guys
want to see in any of those videos I
typically write and shoot and post those
videos on the same day so there's
something that you really wanted to see
I might have a chance to work it into
one of my videos later this week just to
get things started in this first post
here's my top 10 Sherlock moments from
series 1 & 2
number 10 Jim from i.t in the great game
I was totally fooled the first time I
met Jim from IT the scene takes a whole
different context once you find out the
Jim is really James it's a perfect blend
of the unintentional humor of Sherlock
breaking down a person's attributes
Moriarty baiting him with a false
identity and the onlookers like Molly
and Watson being completely embarrassed
awkward Sherlock comedy at its best
number 9 the mind Palace in Hound of
Baskerville
I love how Watson is always making fun
of Sherlock for not knowing loose facts
about mundane things the mind Palace is
Sherlock's answer to all that if you're
not familiar with memory enhancement
it's a real thing they're called
mnemonic devices and they give people
ways to store large amounts of
information in their brains the other
side of that is recall devices and
memory triggers just because you can
store something doesn't mean you'll be
able to pull it out of deep storage so
when you see all those graphics pop up
around Sherlock's head in the episode
what you're seeing is is him using
recall devices to find the information
that he needs number 8 whipping the
corpse in a study in pink this was our
first introduction to Benedict
Cumberbatch's Sherlock it totally
explained the character and a few
strokes of that riding crop unlike
Robert Downey jr. as Vagabond savant
approach to the character Cumberbatch's
Sherlock is hyper focused intense and
deceptively asexual but not altogether
uncaring if you ever wanted to explain
Sherlock to someone who had never seen
it before
that would actually be the scene to show
them number 7 the bloody harpoon during
Hound of Baskerville the episode itself
was not my favorite but the reason I
love this moment so much was that it
gave you a real
that some of their most epic cases were
happening in between the episodes that
we were actually watching all it takes
is one look at Sherlock covered in blood
and a few cursory words about having to
ride the tube and your mind explodes
into this pocket universe where we
actually get to see the case that he
just worked on I like to think of it is
the greater tales of Sherlock as told by
Watson via his blog for anyone that's
curious that bloody spear was actually a
reference to the Conan Doyle story The
Adventures of black Peter number six
Sherlock standoff with Moriarty in the
great game I love the way this episode
ended and the ambiguity of Sherlock's
intentions it's always a game of chess
with those two but would he have shot
the explosives if Moriarty had called
his bluff after seeing how fast
Sherlock's mind can work during scandal
in Belgravia I definitely think he would
have formulated a plan of how to survive
that explosion had he pulled the trigger
that idea hinges planning for every
possible contingency is very important
to learning how he survived during Rican
Bock fall number 5 Irene Adler's battle
suit during scandal in Belgravia it's
not so much her battle suit that was
memorable it was Irene watching Sherlock
try to break her down while she was
breaking him down it really is the
universe telling you that these two
people need to be together but because
of who they are and their backgrounds
they ultimately end in tragedy despite
that I do feel like the finale of that
episode was optimistic or at least left
room for her return laura Pulver was so
amazing as Irene Adler that Amanda
Abbington as Mary Morstan in series 3 is
gonna have a really hard time living up
to her standard number 4 buckingham
palace and pants in scandal in Belgravia
there are so many moments that are
amazing from this episode but the bed
sheet and the banter with Mycroft was so
much fun
just like the explosives in great game
and the roof jump and Rican Bock fall I
definitely think he would have just kept
on walking and been naked in Buckingham
Palace let me know below in the comments
how far you think Sherlock would have
walked out of Buckingham Palace naked
until the Queen's Guard tackled him to
the ground number 3 Moriarty steals the
crown jewels during Rican Bach fall you
don't get to see a lot of Moriarty's
process or him enacting his process but
I loved the way he was so casual about
the whole thing once you learned why he
did it it becomes less of a mystery but
no one on this show has more fun than
Moriarty when he's misbehaving Sherlock
and Watson have a lot of fun and sure
definitely feels this intense
satisfaction whenever he solves puzzles
but I don't think he experiences the
pure ecstasy that Moriarty does whenever
he's doing something awful if any of you
happen to work at the BBC boys
misbehaving would make an amazing
spin-off starring Andrew Scott number
two the rooftop jump during Rican Bach
fall you definitely feel this air
finality but the experience of the
explosives during scandal as well as the
bedsheet and all of Sherlock's other
gambits kind of make you feel like he's
going to get up and just dust himself
off so when I saw him lying there on the
pavement my heart left out of my throat
but also from a meta standpoint whenever
these episodes aired they had not
renewed Sherlock for a third year so
nobody knew whether or not we would
actually get an explanation for what
happened to Sherlock don't worry though
I'll be doing a breakdown video for how
I think he survived the fall tomorrow
and my number one moment the grave site
revealed during Rican buck fall you had
just gone through this intense
experience so when the camera pans away
to a very much alive Sherlock it was a
giant WTF moment remember the series had
not been renewed so people had no idea
what was going on fYI though that will
not be the case this season the season
will totally end on a huge cliffhanger
just like last season but both Benedict
Cumberbatch and Martin Freeman are under
contract for a fourth series no filming
date has been announced but hopefully we
won't have to wait another two years
before finding out what happens after
the events of this new season like I
said I'll be doing a breakdown for how I
think Sherlock survived his fall be sure
to subscribe to get it in addition to
that this is wholock week so I'll be
doing tons more Doctor Who and Sherlock
every single day we've got the Christmas
special we've got the mini episode many
happy returns as well as a bunch of QA
days I'll be doing and breakdowns of
everything right now you can click here
to get that breakdown of how I think you
survived the fall I'll add the
annotation as soon as I post it tomorrow
and you can click here if you want
spoilers for series 3 thank you so much
for watching I'll see you guys tomorrow
high fives
you